la boule de fort ressemble un mélange
entre la pétanque et le bowling le but
est de s'approcher le plus possible du
cochonnet appelé ici le maître le petit
la subtilité du jeu repose sur le
déséquilibre de la poule
elle possède un côté plus lourd que
l'autre d'où son nom boule de fort toute
la difficulté réside dans l'habilité à
maîtriser cette trajectoire quand la
bourse va quitter la main c'est en fin
de compte souvent une fois le majeur
s'il est dans laxe de la baule on aura
une trajectoire pendant a défini si
jamais on déplace le moteur la boule va
commencer à tanguer et la trajectoire
est faux c'est dingue idéal c'est
d'avoir les trois doigts qui sont joints
avec le majeur au milieu en fin de
course la boule va pencher vers son côté
ford est donc changer de direction
il existe un autre paramètre pour
pimenter les parties
c'est utiliser les rebords surélevé de
la piste
selon la légende des mariniers de la
loire aurait inventé ce jeu dans le fond
des gabarres d'autres assurent que ce
sont les prisonniers espagnols qu'ils
auraient pratiqué dans des fossés ce jeu
traditionnel est un éloge de la lenteur
une partie peut durer plus d'une heure
il ya la convivialité de entre
compétiteurs il n'y a pas de rivalité
c'est bon enfant on s'amuse on rigole on
se chambre un petit peu
c'est ce qui donne à la traite se jouer
c'est très très reposante vrai dire pour
sur ce jeu est une distraction
ligérienne recensés depuis le 17e siècle
entre saint nazaire et blois
la boule de fort est officiellement
reconnu que patrimoine immatériel du
pays de la loire sur les 350 clubs
existants l'écrasante majorité se situe
dans le maine et loire la touraine quant
à elle compte une quarantaine de
sociétés ces clubs sont souvent
exclusivement masculin mais la pratique
est ouverte à tous les visiteurs